[Music]
if you want to make a test
of the fundamental theories of the
universe you want to go to the most
extreme laboratories in the universe and
a black hole is that a black hole is the
most mysterious object in the universe
it's when matter gets to be in such a
small space and it's so dense that the
force of gravity prevents even light
from escaping
that's a one-way door from our universe
[Music]
hi friends welcome to another special
episode of the into the impossible
podcast featuring a renowned scientist
dr shep dolmen
of harvard university the founding
director of the event horizon telescope
that released some of the most iconic
images ever captured in science history
and i claim maybe in human history
because it really took the global
village of intellects of minds of money
collaboration around the world and today
shep and i geeked out about what are
these images based upon what's the
technology that goes into them and more
than just the the human drama that we do
discuss what is the technology
technological drama what would einstein
say uh seeing such things and so we went
off on a very deep dive into the
technology which i know that you my
audience the most astute astoundingly
intellectual minds in the multiverse
will appreciate more than almost any
other person on earth uh so please do
share it also with your friends and
family who may be interested as well
then we also did talk about some of the
controversy some of the surprising
things things ranging from uh how do you
lead a collaboration how do you avoid
toxicity how do you handle things like
sexism and uh and some uh repugnant
behavior that took place around the
world when these uh first images shocked
and shook up the universe where do we go
from here in technological space but
also how do we convey to the next
generation of scientists how best to
really work together cooperate and learn
using these teachable moments such as
those that we elucidate in this talk it
was really a phenomenal conversation so
much fun i think it's his first podcast
that he's ever done and we went deep we
went broad and we culminated with the
thrilling three final questions that
you'll have to subscribe uh to the
podcast to view so you can do that on
youtube but i also ask you to do so on
my website briankeating.com but i do uh
request that you sign up and then you'll
get access to the thrilling three
questions and you won't want to miss it
because shep was incredibly vulnerable
and uh and just open authentic and
honest so i think you'll enjoy this
episode of the into the impossible
podcast with dr shep dolman pi of the
next generation event horizon telescope
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
upbeat to begin one of my beginning
interviews of 2022
with a phenomenal scientist uh a pioneer
in the field of imaging black holes and
doing so from literally
the entire surface of the earth from the
south pole to the chilean atacama desert
to uh everywhere else in between and
that's dr shep dolmen of harvard
smithsonian center for astrophysics
joining us all the way from beautiful
downtown cambridge is dr doleman and how
are you today sir
i'm will thank you very much brian good
to be here you are the founding director
of the event horizon telescope eht
you are the principal investigator of
the ng eht the next generation eht
and your senior research fellow at
harvard university and i thought that
we'd start you know normally shep i have
on authors and i ask them like how'd you
come up with this stupid title and name
for your stupid new book like this one
over here i have this author on this
author is always on uh you know where'd
you come up with this dumb idea this
dumb cover title um that's my book
but but you don't have a book yet
although i'm curious if there's
something in the works maybe like your
colleague hino falco who was on the show
earlier in 2021
but
since you don't have a book i want to
start off with what you do and i want to
ask you the question that i ask my
colleagues at study black holes and it
is what fascinates you the most about
black holes
well
black holes play in a lot of different
arenas mathematicians love them
physicists love them even philosophers
get all you know dewey eyed about black
holes and uh and sort of astronomers the
thing that fascinates me most about them
is that it seems as though
they are
the most efficient engines
for changing the universe so when you
look at the night sky it looks the way
it does because black holes exist and we
know so little about them so my whole
career has been trying to figure out
what are they how can we make images of
them and how do we learn more about them
and where did the idea of the event
horizon telescope come from
you know i get that question a lot
and it's one of those
interesting
projects where it has
a lot of different tributaries
all coming together
so you've got
you know einstein thinking about black
holes schwarzschild solving this
equation in the trenches of world war
one
coming up with this idea of a
schwarzschild radius the point at which
nothing can escape from a
gravitationally bound very compact
object
and then
this realization from the observational
point
that there are probably black holes in
the centers of most galaxies which came
from radio astronomy in the 60s and then
in the 70s something very interesting
happened
people began to simulate what a black
hole might look like if it were
at the center of a galaxy or
being fed by a star and there were some
really interesting simulations by a
french
astronomer named jean-pierre lumine and
he was credited with the first
simulation that showed what a black hole
might look like with all the twisty
lensing that happens right near the
event horizon
and uh at the same time people were
using radio interferometry my game
and looking at
very high angular resolution images
and they were realizing that there were
very compact objects in the center of
galaxies
those were probably black holes so now
we have this theory of what they might
look like we had this idea that they
existed
and
probably around
in the mid 90s we began to really focus
on sagittarius a-star
the center of our milky way galaxy where
we think there's a four million solar
mass black hole
and and then there was some
high nose work for example
that showed
what the shadow of the black hole might
look like an extension of jean-pierre's
work
and then we began to realize through
this idea of massive digital signal
processing
harnessing moore's law to make a new
kind of telescope that this was really
possible
and we wrote
a paper for the decatur review
in the um you know for the u.s
decatur review every 10 years all the
astronomers come together and they say
what's new what are we going to do next
and we wrote a paper there and said this
is the decade we will image a black hole
by the end of this decade and we made it
with three months to spare
so the the origin story is that
theory observation all came together
around the mid 90s and the 2000s it
became possible
i believe we were all sitting around
a table at the american astronomical
society meeting
in like 2009 and said event horizon
telescope catchy
and then we were off and running
yeah it's you know funny that people
point out that technology has you know
been around for several decades and you
know in one form or another since janski
in the 1930s
at bell labs but the application and the
confluence of it with digital you know
computer processing correlators etc
make it really come to fruition at this
specific moment in time and perhaps know
earlier
and i wonder if you can talk a little
bit about the technology my audience is
the most astute technological collection
of 56 000 people now and growing uh that
you'll ever find so don't be afraid to
geek out a little bit how do these how
do these instruments work together as a
telescope because it's not called the
event horizon telescopes it's called the
telescope meaning it's a singular
telescope what sense is it a singular
telescope
well since there's a few different
things that come together to make this
all possible
and it's really a question of why now
right because this was the moment
when you could really pull this off
so in the late in the mid 90s people had
made radio interferometric detections of
a black hole right they peered into the
center of our milky way galaxy and
they'd seen something
there
but
we we didn't have the sensitivity to
make an image
and so what we really needed was an
explosion in bandwidth we needed to be
able to record
a hundred times
more data than we had been recording
before to make these images
and and so
we did this by a concerted effort to
harness moore's law and we reimagined
all of the instrumentation that had been
used in the past brought it into the
digital age and that is what made this
possible
now what do you do with those recorders
so the way that very long baseline
interferometry works this is the
technique that we use to turn the earth
into a telescope is we point
all of our telescopes in the array every
telescope on the earth is swivels to
look at the black hole at exactly the
same time we synchronize them all with
gps they all know exactly what time it
is at each station we have atomic clocks
so the ticking is so precise
that when waves come from the black hole
they can be synchronized perfectly into
a plane
and we can then start to really process
these data
we record at each of these sites on high
bandwidth recorders like 64 gigabits per
second
all the data coming from the black hole
and then we we close up shop then we're
done
except that we're not done we've just
begun right so then all of that data is
sent back
uh on hard disk drives to a central
supercomputer
where they're played back
and all of the
data are played back in just the right
way so that
we act as though we've had a parabolic
dish
the size of the earth so all the plane
waves coming from the black hole hit
this virtual
parabola all the delays are encoded in
digital electronics
and we wind up comparing the data that
we record in chile with the data we
record in spain with the data we record
in hawaii
and we create a telescope as large as
the surface of the earth in much the
same way
that an optical dish bounces light off
of its surface and comes to a focus
that's where you put your camera we do
the same thing but in digital
electronics
and
the technology synthesizes this enormous
telescope um and i wonder you know uh
we're kind of presaging some of the
audience questions that we're going to
get to but one of them is you know
relatively astute and and it's kind of
uh focuses no pun intended uh on this
aspect of you know baseline which is
this maximum separation
versus the aperture of each individual
dish
and they're wondering this uh viewer is
wondering you know what if you just had
one tiny little you know put a dish tv
sized dish but you put it at l2 where
the web telescope is you know careful so
they don't bump into each other uh it's
getting crowded out there with plank
wmap and uh and now the web telescope
but uh tell me would you benefit more
from one more telescope like that or
would you benefit more from a south pole
sized telescope or an alma sized
telescope at the north pole uh you know
where would you start to benefit more is
it that bigger is better or is it that
farther is better
so there's a lot to learn about black
holes
and as you can imagine
the kind of telescope you employ
gives you a better look at some science
and then if a different kind of
telescope would give you a good look at
other scientific areas of inquiry
so if you were to put a telescope at l2
that's a great question by the way
fabulous question tell you my audience
is the best and brightest in the
multiverse this this is
an astute crowd so you would wind up
getting an angular resolution that was a
fraction of a micro arc sucker
right so this is the like the equivalent
of seeing
like a human hair on the moon i mean
this is really kind of tiny stuff or
maybe a db on the moon i forget exactly
what the analogy would be yeah but it's
about it would be you know many times
fine or angular resolution that even the
event horizon telescope
can do
and the problem with that
is that you would need to have a pretty
big telescope out there to get the
sensitivity
that you needed to look at the very fine
structures because then you're only
sensitive to the tiniest
structures on the sky
now thankfully
we now know that the ring of light
around the black hole the shadow
consists of multiple concentric rings
each more fine
than the previous one
so what you could do by going out to l2
is start to look at the very fine almost
fractal structure
of this ring which is formed by multiple
orbits of light around the black hole
you just
that blows my mind actually that that
light is trapped to travel in circles
around a black hole and we might see
that
with such a telescope at all too now if
you put a telescope in the north pole or
you added telescopes on the ground
then you'd probably be able to make a
much richer image of the black holes
that we already can see like sagittarius
a star
m87 and that would show us
the flow of material
around the black hole we learned a lot
about accretion so l2 we learn about gr
general relativity makes einstein happy
and
if you had more
sites on the earth we'd learn a lot more
about accretion so we'd make a lot of
astrophysicists happy because then they
learned why black holes shine
right so it's kind of you'd win in all
cases and maybe it'd be controversial if
you were a director of nasa for the 2020
decadal uh survey i mean would you
prioritize i mean the james webb
telescope cost 10 billion dollars which
is equivalent to the lhc and they
launched into space and it's going to do
wonderful things i'm sure
but that kind of swallowed up a huge
portion of astrophysics general uh
budget for the future and doesn't leave
a lot of room for the budget of the lh
of the eht which i think is much much
smaller and um and and i wonder you know
if if you can you know comment on that
and in other words where do you when do
you decide you know uh that the
scientific reach of an instrument
justifies maybe even you know
superseding a new way of looking at the
universe let's call web new even though
it's you know they share some things
with certif and other previous existing
experiments but anyway
how would you as a policy maker
prioritize doing upgrades to eht if you
weren't you know that had a vested
interest in it
yeah well so let me put it this way i
told you before that
in 2010 we submitted a paper to the 2010
decatur review and we said this is what
we'd like to do we think we can image a
black hole by the end of the decade
i didn't tell you the end of that story
the end of that story is that we didn't
make it into the decatur review the
event horizon telescope did not appear
in the decadal report they did not think
it was worthy
but then here we are
in 2019 coming with the first image of a
black hole so the decadal review
and the consensus of all the
astronomers
of repute
taken together is not always in my view
the right one because they overlook the
long shots they overlook the innovation
they overlook the high risk
high payoff
they want to know what the entire
community can get behind with a hundred
percent chance of success in the long
run
and the eht was risky
you know we needed uh champions we
needed happy warriors we needed people
who were gonna risk careers in order to
make that happen
and that's not what the decatur reviews
about
now now that we know that black hole
shadows exist
now i would prioritize it much more
prominently in that report and we did
get fairly good mention in the astro
2020 report but again if i was the nasa
head i would say
full steam ahead
let's let's put something in space to
create
a virtual telescope larger than our
planet
we're going to get to ng eht later but i
do want to ask you know you're very
cautious and circumspect and i respect
that and appreciate that you're talking
a lot about the the light shadow and
these concentric rings um you're less
referring to it as the event horizon
imaging the event horizon talk about is
that just a distinction without a
different ship or is it you know just
you sometimes will call these two
equivalent things the same
well so this is a really interesting
point i mean if you talk to a physicist
about what an event horizon is they'll
have a slightly different view than
an astronomer right so an astronomer is
looking for some kind of
phenomenological
uh
membrane you know so where do you not
see any light uh where do you get this
infinite red shift
and and where can you see light bending
around a physicist will think about it
in terms of the information paradox and
um and conformal field theory
so
your definition of the event horizon and
more importantly your definition of when
you've seen it
will change depending upon your
perspective
so from from our perspective as
astronomers we see this ring of light
and we
realize that this
is the manifestation of all of the
simulations we've ever run so our best
physics our best understanding of gr all
show this feature when there is an event
horizon
so we're happy we're comfortable in that
space we're comfortable saying we've
seen something that we think is the
smoking gun for
an event horizon
now other people will say well have you
really seen
an actual event horizon have you seen
matter disappear
from our
our consciousness our
our sensory apparatus forever
we haven't done that
and even more to the point
people look at this ring and they say
well have you really seen the photon
orbit
right which is a slightly different
thing than seeing a ring of emission
around the black hole
and and and there we think that new
instruments will corroborate our finding
that this is the event horizon of a
black hole uh next generation as you
said there's going to be a new
instrument that will do that
but
uh you'd have to
do some pretty interesting gymnastics
to get out from the fact that this marks
an event horizon but they're i'm
perfectly willing to admit there are non
gr space times uh there are potentially
non-black hole solutions but they tend
to be extremely exotic brian right
and for reference we're talking about
the the portrait that is framed above
your right shoulder in the background of
your office living room wherever you may
happen to be
many people but some of my uh listeners
have as their avatar that picture uh on
facebook for facebook groups it's it's
really an iconic image and it was one of
the few you know really positive things
to come out during the pandemic time uh
kind of united the world in uh in an
awful lot of celebratory non-political
non-biological
pandemic related news that showed what
the human species is capable of one of
my colleagues late great hunting's parr
who's a professor here was a student of
leon letterman at columbia
he used to say that gr was the
culmination of all of western
civilization and i said what do you mean
uh hans you know what what does that
mean say well you know think about what
it takes to get gr to work you need it
to have language mathematics you need to
have you know conversations culture
robust consensus you need to have
arguments and have detractors and and so
forth then you need to publicize it
disseminate get funding for it political
it spans every dimension of of you know
of human interaction so it's it's
rightfully seen as a as a
appropriation of our culture and in fact
einstein himself said um you know when
he was asked you know is he you know how
does he view himself compared to other
scientists he said that he paled and
this is you know a little sock puppet i
have of him um and he he said i pale in
comparison to isaac newton who did even
more for civilization than i did now
this was a human project more than
almost anything else and before we get
to the human you know interest aspects
of it i do want to talk about the
challenges technological and the one
that i'm most familiar with although you
know i have you know participated in
robust discussion about eht but um the
south pole telescope so just today you i
notice you you do have a twitter uh
account which is kind of cool to see so
i'll put a link to that in your in the
graphics or my super producer stewart do
that but uh but i want to ask that
telescope today just tweeted out that
they are installing a new tertiary
mirror uh talk about the importance of
the south pole it has a huge kind of um
soft spot in my heart i do love this i
don't like the south pole as much as i
like uh antarctica mcmurdo et cetera
which is much more pleasant to visit but
um but i've spent some time at the south
pole and you have two right and uh talk
about what the importance of that
particular instrument is i mean as
george orwell said all telescope
baselines are important but some are
more equal than others right so talk
about the south pole telescope why they
upgrade the tertiary my friend john
carlstrom who's a titanic figure um you
know in all of astrophysics he's made so
many discoveries why did he dedicate
this cosmology telescope studying what i
think is the most important thing the
cmb over my shoulder why is the south
pole telescope so important to this
mission of eht
well so
first of all i the south pole telescope
is important
but it's it's it's really a case where
all the telescopes are important because
in in very long baseline interferometry
it's location location location it's
just like real estate
and
and having many telescopes all around
the globe
is quite important now the south pole
telescope has a few attributes that make
it
quite attractive so first of all it's
the best observing
location
just about on the surface of the planet
for what we do i mean at a wavelength of
one millimeter wavelength of 0.87
millimeters you routinely get
unparalleled long periods
of excellent
uh viewing
and excellent weather so that's one
thing and the second thing is that for
one of our sources the
galactic center of the milky way
where there's a four million solar mass
black hole
uh it's at 30 degrees minus 30 degrees
declination so it just circles in the
sky
so you always are able to see that
source so no matter
what other telescope can see sagittarius
a star on the rest of the globe it
always has a partner with the south pole
so south pole is everyone's friend from
that perspective
and and it gives you a very long
north south baseline so as you can
imagine civilization kind of exists in
this band around
the uh the earth
and
we really prize the north-south sites
which can stretch
our resolution which can give us
spatial understanding of what's on the
sky in different dimensions so we really
like the fact that we have a telescope
now in greenland and now also one in in
the south pole
and
what i think is interesting you
mentioned john carlstrom and the cmb the
fact that the south pole has agreed to
work with us
as part of the event horizon telescope
just shows that you can have one cutting
edge application for a telescope in this
great location
and then you can time share you can
deliver even more science by just a few
changes this tertiary mirror a new
receiver that can give you a whole new
dimension of science from that same
location
so it's uh i love this idea of reusing
what we already have i'm a very thrifty
kind of person at heart and i just love
reusing things that we have
to do new things right yes
parsimony is the friend of all
astronomers so the new tertiary and the
new secondary i forgot i'm just looking
up uh amman chukshi's tweet he's down at
the southpaw thing he's their winner
over uh for the upcoming uh austral
winter i tweeted out the uh the new a
picture of those two i'll put those in
the show notes or in the um in the
b-roll footage um so why why did it need
a new one i mean what what couldn't it
do with the existing secondary and
tertiary were those just not optimized
for this uh you know to to provide the
the highest resolution images or is it
necessary to do what we're going to get
to in a minute to look deeper at sage
star for example
so i'm not an expert on the south pole
telescope i'm the wrong person to give
you the the lowdown and the inner scoop
on that
the secondary i imagine is being redone
because they just want better acuity and
better optics and better throughput for
their telescope they want to always put
new instruments down there for the
cosmic microwave background
the the tertiary mirror
i think is interesting for the eht
because it may lead to
a mode where
we can quickly switch
between what the south pole normally
does
and the eht
because the
the south pole normally uses a volometer
array which is not suitable for the work
that we do with the event horizon
telescope and we need to switch to a
different kind of receiver
it used to be that you'd have to go out
in the your austral winter in your minus
50 degrees to bolt a new mirror onto the
south pole telescope order to do the ehd
work and i think this is going to lead
to a much
much easier process
for switching from one to the other
excellent so let's turn to the uh to the
next topic which is uh the difference
between the different kinds of black
holes that you can image they're all
super massive right you're not imaging
you know the same types of black holes
that say ligo
has detected
and yet they're very complementary
obviously they're very important uh
first of all you know there is a
misconception that our galaxy you know
is somehow orbiting around our sage star
that it's responsible for our is that is
that correct that our gal the
supermassive black hole at the center of
the milky way called sage star
uh is the uh is the essential mass that
keeps our galaxy in orbit
oh yeah so even though it is at pretty
much the dynamical center of our galaxy
it's because it's settled there
the mass of the supermassive black hole
in the milky way galaxy
is a tiny fraction of the entire mass of
the whole galaxy i mean our whole galaxy
might have 10 of the 11 stars or
something like that and sanjay starr is
maybe a 4 million stars so it's a very
very small fraction of the total mass of
our galaxy right
and indeed it's also black holes make up
unfortunately a minuscule amount of the
dark matter or you know on invisible
matter as i understand it um and yet
there is hope uh both for you know
detecting
the similar kinds of patterns and so
forth um that you detected in m87 and
the iconic image behind you but also for
sajstar so um can you talk about you
know presuming that is going to come out
someday and chronologically
speaking it will have to be after m87
was detected if it ever does come out
can you talk about what made the choice
of was there a choice to prioritize one
versus the other um some you know the
closer one versus a more massive one um
how did that um if optimization program
work on a technical level as i'm
continuing to to you know to hammer home
the audience is really keen to hear
about what scientists are actually
thinking
to make these breakthroughs not just the
pretty pictures that result from them
yeah it's a great question brian
so
for a long time sagittarius a star was
thought to be our primary target because
there was
incontrovertible evidence that there was
something there and of course last year
uh reinhard genzel and andre aguez won
the nobel prize for their work nailing
down
the fact that there was a very very
massive object in the center of our
galaxy almost certainly a black hole
so we knew what its mass was we knew its
location it became the fixation
for astronomers across many many
different wave bands
yours truly included as well as a lot of
my colleagues
but then
around 2010
i mean 2010 2009
we realized that there might be some
other opportunities
for imaging
this light bending around an event
horizon that causes the shadow and in
fact if you go back to jean-pierre
illuminae's 1979 paper
he has a wonderful sentence in there
and he says this may
be the kind of thing you would see
at the heart of m87
so even in 1979 he i think he was the
first person to say maybe this will
happen for for m87
so
in 2009 we made observations of m87 and
we detected it
and then we published in 2012
uh the evidence that there was something
really compact there equally as compact
in terms of the schwarzschild radius
scale as what we had seen in the center
of our own galaxy now we had two sources
to look at yeah uh so
that's huge i mean you're doubling your
your target base right
and and then uh
something very interesting comes into
play then because m87 is about a
thousand times more massive
than sagittarius a star and the
dynamical time scale let's geek out for
a minute brian that the orbital period
around a black hole is directly
proportional to its mass
so for sagittarius our things move
around the black hole in half an hour
so imagine that you're looking at this
black hole during an evening and you
want to add all your data together as
the earth rotates
and you can't do it because what you're
trying to look at changes its appearance
from moment to moment it's like taking a
picture of a runner sprinting by taking
the lens cap off your your camera you
get a
blur right
so to do that you have to make a movie
of what you're seeing so it requires a
lot more data a lot more finesse
a lot more algorithmic work frankly
but for m87
it's so massive that it doesn't change
for a whole week or for a whole week it
might stay roughly the same
shape and morphology it's like the
buddha it's like sitting there just not
moving just
very very strong
it's like homer simpson i say it looks
like a doughnut homer simpson's taking a
bite
m87 has given rise to a lot of memes
let's put it that way
but but it's just sitting there and
while the earth rotates
it waits for its picture to be taken so
all the data from a night of observing
can be added together
and you get a lot of data to make a
great image so that's why we went
and came with the m87 image first
because it was easier
because when we put together all the
data for m87 it was so clear that we had
a iron-clad result
a result that was really clear and true
for m87 we started
analyzing the data at the same time but
it rapidly became
apparent to us it was more complicated
and that's why we're continuing to work
with those data now i'm
fairly certain that
soon we will have some results on
sagittarius a star but it's taken a long
time
because we had to develop a lot of the
analysis techniques to deal with the
fact that it was changing
yeah and that brings up another you know
technical question but uh the the
advances in numerical relativity and um
in prediction i remember seeing some of
those plots from the 70s you know it's
like hand-drawn and pencil or it was on
a on a dot matrix printer and they're
really quite beautiful and and they look
exactly like you know the some of the
reprocessed images that i've seen
to what extent is the image behind you
you know i often hear this um because
i've gotten into uh the the person that
re we've known you and i have known each
other for a little bit but uh it took
our friend mutual friend avi loeb uh
who's somewhere nearby uh your office
there at cfa or at harvard and he
reintroduced us together and uh and then
that led to this interview so we have
avi lopez he's a great matchmaker uh so
um when avi was on last summer a couple
times on the into the impossible podcast
we talked a lot about aliens and and
detection and so forth of uap phenomena
of course
which um now that i am a external
advisor on the galileo project i have
received my own uh sample of a muammua
so avi gave me a piece of umu no i'm
just kidding this is just a meteorite
okay uh but um but these objects you
know coursing across the sky and then
that brought up in the public's mind
especially when the pentagon released
these data
over the summer and this kind of bland
position report about it uh it could be
it's worth studying
um people started saying we want the
data we want data from these astronomers
and and my point is fine but you have to
treat it the way that we treat our data
in other words you have to say all the
things that go into the image that could
be artifacts that could be
biases that could be you know
relics and remnants of unwanted signals
and i pointed like the hubble deep field
i like to be provocative i see the
hubble deep field is not data it's an
image and and yes there's some data you
can count how many galaxies there are
you can make an estimate how many
galaxies are in the universe you can see
how many of them are red how many are
elliptical you could do some analysis
but it's not the same as the raw data
right so that's the raw data now what is
an amateur going to do with that or a
non-expert amateur i mean amateurs do a
lot in astronomy as you know but but
someone who's you know knows nothing
about data processing very little so the
question after that rambling preamble is
you know the image behind you to what
extent is that data or is it merely and
there's nothing wrong with it is it
merely sort of a pretty picture in other
words do you analyze that or do you
actually have to go deeper and if so how
do you go deeper to extract gr and
numerical comparisons to numerical gr
yeah it's a really good question first i
want to tackle the data question
because we're only as good as our data
and we have to create an iron-clad chain
of custody if you will
all the way from the telescope
you know with these hard disk drives to
the correlator
to the astronomers doing the analysis
and then to the image and we have to
explain every step very very carefully
the first thing i'll say is that we had
duplication every step of the way we
never had one
person we never had one group we never
had one software
um package that was responsible for
something that we didn't understand or
couldn't compare
to something else so just think about
the data pipelines
we had three different independent
pipelines handling the data and they all
had to give the same result
we had two separate correlators one in
germany
and one in at mit
processing the raw data
into these interferometric data set that
we imaged
and then we had three different
imaging softwares we had a very
historical traditional one called clean
which was developed in the 70s that
astronomers
know and love we get all right
you know warm and runny when we think
about clean
um but then we developed two new lines
of imaging software that were
tailor-made for the ehtm we
intercompared them all
and and then we also looked at different
simulations we didn't trust one
simulation of what we were supposed to
be seeing we used many different
simulation packages and we cross
referenced all of them so every step of
the way we had
what i like to call a creative tension
it was creative because we were doing
something new and we were comparing with
each other
but also
it was verification you had to show that
what you were getting was consistent
with what somebody else was getting
across the whole project so so your
listeners should be very
um
confident that we treated the data and
this analysis
very carefully every step of the way
now then there's this question that you
raise which is what is this above my
right shoulder like what you know what
what is that
so
we we approached this in a couple of
different ways we modeled it so we said
what is the best fit model to this and
the models that we used were different
kinds of rings or we used doubles we
used many different kinds of
modeling techniques and i can assure you
that of all of them
the shadow model that this like
concentric
crescent
is by far and away the most probable
okay so in models you always look for
the most probable
and then we used imaging techniques like
three as i described to you
and all of them gave this particular
image
and which is in some sense a best fit
image i mean there are some images that
also fit but this is the general form of
all of the images that fit well
and and the last point is
that we didn't trust ourselves
i mean there's human
drama that comes into any kind of
endeavor like this right
so we we divided ourselves into four
separate teams
all of whom had the data but we couldn't
talk to each other
and
every group had to analyze the data
completely independently so there was no
bias so there wasn't group think
everyone got in the room and said we're
all seeing a shadow of course we're
seeing a shadow why wouldn't we see a
shadow of course yes
each group found the shadow
independently
and then we also tried to make it go
away
so we we tried to fit it
with
doubles we tried to fill it with we
tried to fit it with a fitted filled
disk
without the shadow dimple inside of it
we did everything we could and the data
always steered us back
to this image and it was really the fit
to the data as you said brian
that is the ultimate coin of the realm
and and that is what we used to convince
ourselves that this shadow is real
and i think that you know follows
perfectly you know feynman's
dictum
which is you know the the first
principle is that you should not fool
yourself
the second principle is you're the
easiest person to fool and i always add
the third principle is uh you must not
fool richard feynman because that's just
cruel
but doing this and doing these blind
analyses and doing these multiple
analyses is kind of an example of what
the military calls a red team you know
approach where you've got adversaries
who hopefully you know are
loving each other share the same mission
you know they want to defeat the enemy
or protect the country uh and so but
they have radically different approaches
some think we should have a navy only
some say we should have only an air
force yeah whatever so but taking this
approach adversaries that that combat
with love uh you know i think that's
incredibly important before we get into
uh the the softer science aspects as you
talked about in the collaboration the
social science aspects i do just want to
close out some of the technical
commentary and that is you mentioned
several times a correlator
now i've used correlators in
radioastronomical applications um you
know my whole career such as it is uh
but but these correlators are very
different in that as i understand
they're effectively like a super
homebrew supercomputer in some sense so
can you talk about what is the what is a
correlator and you mentioned you have
two of them why why why is it necessary
to have two of them but not two south
pole telescopes or two alma edition
uh although yes of course you have
multiple telescopes but why is the
correlator itself so neces so you know
important and crucial that you actually
need two of them
right right it's good it's a good point
so i want to back up a little bit this
this technique that we use to make this
event horizon telescope
it it there's a little magic to it but
essentially what we're doing is we're
taking data from a network of radio
dishes across the globe all of whom are
looking at the black hole at the same
time
now
we if we had an optical
dish looking at the black hole light
from the black hole would hit all the
different points on this dish and the
shape of the dish would focus it all
to one point and that's where you put
your camera we talked about this a
little bit before
with vlbi we have telescopes all over
the world we record the data as it comes
in
time tag it with atomic clocks at each
location so we know exactly when each
trough and crest of these waves are
recorded on the hard disks then we have
to compare them we have to come we have
to bring them all back to a virtual
focus so we have to take the data we
recorded in chile and combine it with
the data we recorded in spain for
example
in the same way that the optical dish
bounces the light so it arrives at
exactly the same moment at the focus
so the the correlator what the
coordinator does is it plays back these
recordings
and
delays or advances them perfectly in
time to account for the shape of the
earth and relativity and things like
this so they come together at this
virtual focus
and
they basically just
uh multiply and add the data together
okay so they combine it just the way the
light be combined and focus of one of
these optical dishes and then every
baseline pair every pair of telescopes
gives you one
essential essentially one pixel
of the image that you're trying to to uh
to develop
so the correlator does play a critical
role it combines all the data after the
fact from across the event horizon
telescope array and it winds up giving
us
baseline pair data that we then use to
make the image behind me
why do we need two of them
the reason we have two of them
is because two exist
but it allows us to send half the data
to one and half the data to the other
and then we cross fertilize we send a
little bit of the same data between each
of the correlators to make sure they're
giving the exact same results
one more test that we ran and then we
combined the data from the two
correlators to make this image
excellent
so now let's turn
a little bit more towards the
theoretical aspects of black holes which
bewitch and bemuse you know millions
around the globe and you know two things
are most prominent uh that i talk about
on this channel at least with guests
ranging from sir roger penrose
to reinhard genzel and to
theorists from frank wilcek
to uh to
people like martin reese and that is uh
two different notions one black hole
singularities
and the question of quantum gravity and
the other one is the black hole
information paradox which i talked a lot
about with lenny suskin so let's first
talk about this now you're an
experimentalist you're not creating new
theories and you're doing observations
you're not responsible for for also
coming up with new theories of
relativity or new ways to interpret it
but just you know person to person human
to human
when you think about uh the existence of
singularities uh do you believe
singularities are real
um if so you know can we understand them
better through the event horizon
telescope and if not real
um i'd ask you to speculate on
the prospects for quantum gravity to
unify quantum mechanics and gravity so
whichever way you choose it'll lead us
down a world line of interesting import
uh to my audience
yeah so so
let me just say as as a disclaimer i'm
not a theoretical physicist so i don't
usually say either
of my best friends are though i know i
date my daughter i let them date my
daughter it's okay yeah and and they
make for good cocktail party guests
um
so but that being said black holes are
fascinating i mean as far as we know a
singularity does form at the center of
the black hole shielded of course
because of the cosmic
uh censorship conjecture from our view
and
and this is of course some of the best
evidence that we have that we don't
really know everything i mean this is
where gravity and quantum mechanics
really have to combine at that
singularity
so so what happens in the inside the
event horizon is of great interest to
mathematicians and physicists
and and uh
and the mystery of the
information paradox now at the at the
level of the event horizon i tend to
think
that that's a classical region right so
so for example the m87
event horizon
you and i if we were fell through that
we wouldn't even know we had fallen
through it right the curvature of
space-time is so low that we would just
kind of
pass right through it we wouldn't even
know that we were no longer visible to
the rest of the universe right here you
know you don't need quantum mechanics to
really understand what happens there i
mean we're still eating our
cheeseburgers or whatever we're doing as
we fall through
that event horizon no for for a solar
mass black hole or a few solar masses
that it's much different there you go
you spaghettify pretty quickly because
the tidal forces are such that your feet
are ripped off
your body and and hilarity ensues as
they say
but
so one of the questions that you ask is
can the eht
say something about quantum gravity can
we learn something about the singularity
and there
my first answer is kind of no
that we're in this range where
our sensory apparatus that we've built
with this earth-sized telescope can only
look at this classical
construct that shields the inner
complexity of the black hole but there
are some ideas
that the quantum mechanical states of
the black hole could leak out they could
tunnel
across the event horizon and you might
wind up seeing
a horizon scale manifestation
of those quantum states
and there have been some papers
published and i pay close attention to
these papers
where they say
if
there are some
you know elements of the interior of the
black hole
that uh
line up perfectly you could wind up with
changes in the shadow shape
or changes in the temporal behavior of
the shadow and that would be kind of
interesting to look for
um i'm not sure how
you know probable it is that we'll see
something like that but you never say
never where black holes are concerned
right and and then there's the other
you you didn't mention this but but i'll
i'll mention it uh
with your permission
that
we might not be looking at a black hole
i mean there is the possibility that
we're looking at you know a black hole
mimic you know like some kind of a
gravistar or
or some kind of boson star now i view
these as as highly
non-probable i mean they're very exotic
constructs i mean i know how to make a
black hole kind of a matter of falling
in on itself i don't know how to make a
bozon star i don't know how to make some
of these other exotic things
and
and there are some people in our
collaboration who think about how you
could tell the difference
between these and there's some very
interesting work going on there too so
the fundamental nature of these objects
is front and center
yeah i mean i pointed that out when i
spoke to uh to reinhard uh earlier this
year
you know that the citation the nobel
committee gave it didn't say for you
know imaging the black hole at the
center of the milky way it said imaging
a compact object and using it as a
laboratory for testing gr which at its
core it is as is m87 whatever you've
seen the preponderance of it you can
never say never but the proponents of
evidence seems to suggest that it is a
black hole
and yet uh you know to call it a a
compact object is eminently more correct
uh but it might not be as provocative
and descriptive and that's why
i want to get your thoughts about this
uh information paradox which we hear a
lot about and every so often uh the
friends of mine like sabine haasenfelder
who's been a guest on the show she's
kind of a little bit of a snarky you
know cantankerous uh scientist
theoretical physicist and she always
whenever there's a new paper about the
black hole information paradox she goes
oh it's been solved again you know so
it's the
question is it really a paradox is it
just hype uh she claims it's it's
complete hype and many people do because
it relies on sort of on something you
know
associated with hawking radiation which
is you know
in principle observable but in practice
unobservable just the time scales
involved
and yet and yet
when i had lenny suskind on he said that
the what he calls the stretched horizon
which is i think a one plank length
above the event horizon is the most
interesting aspect not the singularity
and so talk about what else we can learn
that's surprising um from let's talk
about the next generation
event horizon can that in that telescope
will you be able to
learn more about you know getting ever
closer to the event horizon such that
perhaps
you specifically could continue your
collaboration that you lead could
comment on the information paradox and
help to resolve it from an experimental
point of view rather than just you know
people like hawking conceding it you
know to a bet uh to win a bet with john
prescott past guest on the show um so
talk about that can the ngv eht what is
it and how will it improve our knowledge
potentially or not of the information
loss paradox
yeah well there's a lot to unpack there
um
i like your show
so
uh
so
um so the first thing is that the just
briefly the ngeht
is is the next phase of the eht
and we want to add uh enough sites
around the globe to double the number of
dishes that are working and because the
number of baseline pairs then
increases as the square of the number of
dishes we get four times as much data
we're increasing our bandwidth for
sensitivity
and what we want to do is move from
making still images of black holes to
movies
and and more than that we want to
increase the frequency of the
observations which then increases our
angular resolution so the sharpness of
these images will increase
and and that's important again to the
potentially the information paradox
because as i mentioned earlier in the
show
the shadow is made up of concentric
rings
and these happen for the following
reason
the most of the bright emission you see
in this shadow feature is light that's
bent around the black hole that comes
directly to us from behind the black
hole and is bent around it
but there's an interior ring that we
call the n equals one ring for
non-obvious but geeky reasons
where the light has made a u-turn around
the black hole so it's really sampling
now the intense curvature
of space-time when it goes around
and then that ring is interior to that
shadow
and it's much thinner so it encodes in a
more detailed way
gr
and the space time around the black hole
now there's an infinite number of these
rings that the n equals two ring is made
up of photons that do a full u-turn they
won't make an orbit around the entire
black hole
they are now sensing
the space time much closer to the event
horizon and you can imagine as you go to
n equal 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 that you're
getting asymptotically close
to the true horizon the true photon
orbit
right
now the longer these photons stay in
this area
the more
probability
that
the higher the probability that they
could start to either scatter off of
some quantum state
or they could
sense something
that happens on very long time scales
so potentially
and we would have to have we'd have to
build a
next next next generation
event horizon telescope but if we could
parlay this
this infinite nest of rings
into
a sensory apparatus that potentially
could be
um
we could potentially tell us something
about the quantum state's interiors of
the black hole that would be something
that could start to tell us something
about the information paradox you know
or this one plank length
uh stretched horizon above the true
horizon
so it's not a it's not a great answer
but we're always thinking about the next
thing
and
and and black holes are so strange
they're so fractal in the way they bend
light that this could just be
uh an inroad into what the interior of
the black hole looks like
excellent um so before we turn to the
human interest portion of the podcast i
want to ask a couple of more
a couple of more questions the technical
bent this one coming from another
audience member who is asking in general
about the prospects for multi-messenger
learnings about black holes courtesy of
eht and ng eht plus x where x could be
anything but i'm going to add meerkat
which just last week had these
incredible images in the radio meerkats
a precursor to the square kilometer
array which will be the biggest radio
telescope of its kind ever ever deployed
um not the longest baseline you guys
on
that distinction uh at least until
somebody you know elon builds a another
space interometer in space
but i want to ask you about the
prospects for multi-messenger astronomy
and what you thought when you saw the
meerkat images which are just just
stunning to look at and in particular if
you do
you know release a sagittarius a-star
and i hope that you'll do that you know
here first before you go to some aps
press card you'll come on the into the
impossible podcast with yours truly and
you'll announce it and then later you'll
go to stockholm or where we're going to
go but anyway
answer this question please if meerkat
if eht does image sage star could you
immediately use some of the data from
meerkat or other high precision uh
measurements in a completely different
radio wavelength
yeah yeah really really good and again
another astute question so first the
multi-messenger aspect and we'll get to
meerkat in a moment
um
there are huge potential
connections between the eht and many
other facilities you know where we're
now
at the smallest scales
where you can study black holes we're at
the event horizon we're seeing light
bending around it
and when you look at these black holes
in the x-ray when you look at them in
the infrared
um even in gamma rays a lot of the
emission we think comes from right near
the event horizon so so one of the games
that we like to play
is
looking at flaring activity because when
you're so close to the black hole it's
roiling it's bubbling it's boiling and
every once in a while you'll get a
magnetic reconnection event we think
where magnetic fields are so
torqued up they're so twisted they're so
intertwined they will then snap
reconnect and release huge amounts of
energy and we get flares so if you look
at the
sanjay star in the center of our galaxy
you'll see x-ray flares that are 50
times the normal fluids 50 times the
amount of energy normally coming out of
them
and if we could catch that
with the ehg we could tell you what was
happening
when that flare went off right you could
see it erupt
in the image potentially and and that
would tell us a huge amount about how
black holes accrete
how they
deform the space time around them how
they launch jets so this is one of the
real
key questions for modern astronomy and
it relies completely on multi-messenger
we need to see it in the x-ray so we
understand how all the electrons are
emitting across the spectrum we need to
see it evolved spatially
and and that will tell us a lot about
what's happening very close to the black
hole
now for meerkat
the first of all those images are
astounding yeah i mean
as they say you can't make that up i
mean there are some really crazy
structures in the center of our galaxy
exploding supernovae pulsars zipping off
in different directions
something called the mouse something
called the snake i mean it's you have to
think about the animal kingdom just to
capture the
the richness of what we're seeing
but
uh interestingly
the eht and meerkat don't actually play
too well together because meerkat is at
such a lower frequency
so
uh sagi star for example is kind of
shrouded
by this plasma and it's only by going to
very high frequencies that we can see
all the way to the center of the black
hole if meerkat were to look at
sagittarius a star it would just see
this blob
and and so meerkat is looking on much
wider type size scales
and the ehg because of its
intense resolving power
only can really look at a very small
portion of the sky so
they're not
meerkat
creates the context in which sagi star
exists in which we study it with the ehd
but it'd be hard to look at the data
simultaneously
between the two
the two instruments
got it
um so we'll come back to maybe some
technical things when we finish out our
uh audience question segment i hope you
have uh 15 more minutes chef is that
okay oh yeah absolutely okay awesome so
we've presented a story of you as a
scientist but now i want to take a step
back and talk about you as a human being
and uh things that that interest you and
things that drive you and
allow you to persevere past the many
many challenges human technical
uh political financial
uh cultural that you've had to endure
but let me let's go back really far back
and i've asked this of the you know
dozen nobel laureates i've had on the
show and i want to ask you um so what
what drew you to what you do now
uh in your youth was there something in
particular that that you know initiated
this love of astronomy and then led to
you know radio astronomy as your
particular sub-specialty
wow uh you know i don't think so i was
not a boy astronomer you know i wasn't
grinding my own lenses i wasn't you know
out in the backyard with a with a
telescope anything like that i did see
an eclipse when i was 13 which made a
huge impression on me total
uh eclipse of the sun um
1980.
um
but
you know i i think i got i caught the
bug when i went to antarctica
uh so i after i graduated college i
graduated pretty early i was only about
19 when i graduated i was kind of burned
out
and i saw this note that said go to
antarctica you know like do all this
crazy amazing wages
a certain debt chance of death like the
uh
the shackleton advertisement that
appealed
yeah nothing like joining the shackleton
expedition uh there was a stowaway
apparently on that on that one yeah
that's right
um so
but i i got down there and i really got
bitten by the bug of doing science in
challenging circumstances
you know what what do you do when you're
really you have to be self-reliant
if you want to fix something you have to
fix it yourself there's no radio shack
down the road
and so i really liked that
and then when i got to mit for grad
school
i
got connected fairly quickly with this
vlbi group doing
this radio interferometric observing
because i like going to different places
making
these systems work bringing all the data
back together making these
uh images of the sky with unparalleled
angular resolution
but
but like everybody
we all want to discover something new
like
doing incremental science is fantastic i
mean that's the way most science is done
we all get together we move the ball
down the field
but but i think that some of
a lot of us are just thinking god how
can i just do something
really out there
and and that was
this project the eht
you know we i looked at this and after
doing the
um you know paying my dues you know
doing all the the grunt work to learn
radio interferometry and and doing a lot
of observations
i saw this opportunity and i said no
one's really working on this everyone
thinks this is a too hard it's not the
right time
uh we'll never get the funding for it
and i threw myself into it
and it turns out that when you do that i
think um
was it good to said you attempt great
things and cosmic forces will come to
your aid that kind of thing uh i'm not
sure if you said that but
but it really was that kind of thing we
got a small group together we made our
first
observations with the entirely new
instrumentation purpose built for this
experiment
and we took risks
and that was the big thing that we took
risks
and so if you ask me what got got me
into this
it was
the love of instrumentation
but also
the
just the confidence that we could do
something that was really
meaningful and interesting and new
yeah something deep and uh and undone
just let me see
so when i think about uh you know people
that coming up obviously there are
always you know challenges it sounds
like you were burned out at a certain
point and then this reinvigorated this
new intellectual passion for you
um for somebody that's struggling with
such things themselves you know burnout
is quite real i make the joke sometimes
that i you know as an astronomer i spend
more time on telecons than telescopes
um how do you deal with the burnout you
know lately with you know the
proliferation of zoom you know is great
on one hand because we can have all
these meetings instantaneously you don't
have to travel get on an airplane you
know get sick and then bring it back and
then you know lose time traveling or
commuting even
but um but what have we lost and how do
you personally deal with these you know
the challenges the burnout you know it's
a real phenomenon in academia and and
even a lot of my listeners that aren't
in academia this new reality that we're
living in with multi-continental
collaboration
has kind of put you in a unique position
to comment on it so how do you deal with
it what's your routine like do you have
any tips for listeners
yeah is it well
so first of all that the h2 was has
always been a global
endeavor
you know we reached across borders
so first of all that the eht was has
always been a global
endeavor
you know we reach across borders we tap
into expertise wherever we find it we
by the nature of the project we have to
bring telescopes together so there's uh
there's this sense that either we do
this together or we don't do it at all
i think there's an african proverb i've
heard that says if you want to go fast
go alone
if you want to go far go together
so at first we went fast but then to
image the black hole we had to go
together so there was an understanding
that
this really was a moment for the world
to come together in a certain way
and solve a problem that no one group
could do by themselves so that that was
definitely part of it
but
you know we we do struggle with the
collaboration aspect of it
um we've always been on zoom we've
always been on telecons but now we're
100
on telecons and people are burning out
uh because you need that face-to-face
contact one of the ways i describe it to
my team
is that on zoom it's very difficult to
be quiet
so when when i sit in front of a white
board with my team
and we're all scribbling things on the
whiteboard at some point there's a
moment
when everybody just stops talking
and people are just digesting what
they're seeing and they're going through
their own internal process
and they're trying to think about what
comes next
and on zoom you don't have that silence
so there's a way in which people
when they get together operate
differently than on zoom so if people
are getting burned out i hear you if
people think things are not normal i
hear you
uh we are muddling along as best we can
and um and now i'm thankful that we're
able to start meeting in person again so
at harvard where we have the the black
hole initiative offices we are coming
together
and uh
we're sitting in front of whiteboards
and it's working out well
but it's um
it's a challenge it really is the the
ehg result
resonated with a lot of people i mean we
we conservatively estimate that a
billion people have seen this image
so it was on the front page about every
newspaper
on the planet
so it was a moment when everybody's eyes
were fixated on one thing at one time
and and when you combine that with the
near instantaneous
twitter sphere and the near
instantaneous social media sphere
you you create an environment where
where the unintended can happen the
unintended almost must happen
and in addition to all the wonderful
coverage that we got and then the
wonderful interviews that i gave that
katie gave that many people in the
collaboration gave
there were
things that people grabbed onto
that i think were a little bit darker
and you know katie is an absolutely
wonderful researcher and she played a
a
a a key role in all of the work that we
did
um as well as other junior collaborators
we have early career scientists really
were the lifeblood of this of this uh
collaboration
and and i would say that
people came to to her defense
um
it was it was quite unfortunate
i think that the people who were
criticizing uh the process or
who went negative did not understand
the the way we work as a team
and uh and
and that's really what this was it was a
team effort
and so for for them to pick apart the
team
was something that was foreign to all of
us
and it was unwelcome
and i don't think it was right
and and thankfully we also supported
katie and
uh and she's now gone on to be junior
faculty at caltech and is doing
absolutely wonderfully as are many of
the
early career people in our group
um and so i think that in the end
as
as my departed mom used to say living
well is the
best revenge maybe or
maybe many people say that but uh
so just relying on the team and
understanding internally what we did
was give us a lot of security
so uh last a couple questions from the
audience
have to do with
with aspects of relativity
that
perhaps may or may not be
particularly relevant but let me ask
them can you see other sources compact
objects you said before you can't rule
out that this isn't some kind of
dark star boson star whatever
are there other potential target
science opportunities with eht as it is
for looking at massive
objects that may not be black holes
that's very interesting so so the eht is
also looking at
other black holes
for which we don't have the angular
resolution to see the shadow but where
we can see the jets
that are powered by the black holes as
they emerge from the center part of the
galaxy and understanding how those uh
collimate how they accelerate how they
transport energy and matter across
galactic scales that's an entirely new
and interesting and exciting cottage
industry so you know it's one of those
situations where in our spare time we
also look at these
incredibly interesting other sources too
so there's a lot that the eht can do
when it's not looking at the shadows
there are also astronomical mazors so
these are sources where
you get amplification of light in a
certain wave band just like a laser
pointer that you might use during a
presentation but it happens in space on
much larger scales and some of those
molecular transitions occur
in the wave band of the eht so we may be
able to use the ht to study
dying stars or star forming regions
where some of these
lasers and masers occur
in the atmospheres of stars so a
completely different kind of context so
we're we're looking at this interesting
technique and we're finding new
applications all the time
and lastly uh talk about the uh the
images of the polarization
one of my favorite topics what did that
add to our understanding of m87 and what
future um uh you know incarnations of
the polarimetric capabilities of eht
will potentially lead to
in or and without ng eht
right so the polarization
images were really wonderful
because the whole reason the black holes
shine
in the radio
is because of synchrotron radiation and
that's
high speed high energy electrons
orbiting magnetic fields if there are no
magnetic fields you're not seeing any of
this radiation
so
we knew there were these magnetic fields
but understanding the structure of them
also tells you how the black hole is
feeding
so there's one mode of feeding in which
you have something called a magnetically
arrested disc
where
the plasma that's funneling towards the
black hole pushes the magnetic field
so that it becomes stiff and it stops
any more accretion from happening so
it's it's an arrested disc and that has
one
form of magnetic field around it then
you have standard and normal evolution
which is more of a
of a torturous kind of uh
random magnetic field that operates
around the
black hole
and we're now being able we're now
telling the difference between these so
we're now looking at the m87 realizing
that it does seem to operate like a
magnetically arrested disk and so now we
understand from these magnetic fields
how matter is actually getting funneled
through the event horizon so it's a big
advance
an incredible interview
a really wonderfully vulnerable side of
you which will delight
my audience but also very technical
nerdy and fun uh which will delight you
know the other half of my audience
uh so i i do want to express my deep
gratitude on behalf of myself my
listeners uh for going into the
impossible with yours truly and spending
so much of your valuable time on me uh
and i wish you the best in your success
and and uh offer you our deepest
gratitude for opening with your
colleagues this phenomenal view of the
universe
well thanks very much brian it's been a
pleasure
thanks
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]